thanks for coming to my talk I've never
really figured out the elevator pitch
for this thing and whenever I described
it and met with either the blankest of
blank stares or reckless enthusiasm
so welcome reckless and organ
enthusiasts it's a safe place here a
Hammond organ the pinnacle of human
achievements I know a lot of you've been
advised by your legal departments to
never look at any patents I promise that
anything in here is long expired
hopefully you'll permit me a brief
introduction since I'm new to this stage
my name is Peter Tyco mondai fide
software for a living my face looks like
and I'm Pete Eichmann most places that
you'd care to check as early heads up I
won't be taking questions as part of
this talk but please find me here online
I really want to chat about all this I
spent the first few years of my career
working on Linux on the desktop in the
first few years of Linux on the desktop
hopefully some of you will remember this
one Enys I mean Chrome users here any
who weren't employees of simians by my
reckoning the true year of Linux on the
desktop was 2001 but shout out to the
Simeon and the ezel people here the
audience I worked on this custom netbook
class operating systems sort of a
Chromebook before Chromebooks until the
first wave of tablets swept that market
away this company little plays a small
part in the narrative later ooh and now
I'm at fastly an edge cloud platform we
extend existing cloud infrastructure to
provide advanced application delivery
and cloud security I mostly work on
image optimization blog streaming and
metric streaming as well as of course
leading our Hammond organ synthesis team
but since years before any of that I'd
been smitten with the sound of a Hammond
organ I first remember noticing Georgie
Fame backing Van Morrison but I'm sure
that I'd heard one before the Hammond
has been successful in most Chandra's of
music but this talks emotional center is
instrumental soul the stack sound Booker
T and the MGS green onions
[Music]
why are you here you're all accomplished
ham and Organists sick of carting your
instruments around now as a software
developer I get this - we're constantly
fighting against unwieldy constructs and
things that don't fit where we need to
put them together they we're gonna
replace your Hammond with the device
that you could deliver with a single
postage stamp but let's take a moment to
appreciate how far we've already come
the first hammond organ was introduced
as a portable version of this thing to
tell harmonium in 1906 one of the
earliest audio synthesizers like the
Hammonds the telharmonium is an additive
synthesizer it built its sound by
summing together many individual
frequencies each the output of a sine
wave oscillator additive synthesizers
have an inherent parallelism that can
make them difficult to implement
sequentially and now diff synthesizers
sort of the reverse of a frequency
display like you might see on a stereo
or if you've done work in the frequency
domain it's an inverse fourier transform
so let's hear what it hear what it
sounds like to add together two sine
waves together here we'll combine a
single frequency and then another one
that's an octave above to make the
waveform that's below I'm not gonna be
playing anything live here I heard the
demo gods earlier this year with an act
of hubris but all sounds from here from
here on out were produced by this talk
synthesizer
very quiet at this point but does that
like your Hammonds that tell harmonium
was also unwieldy this console first of
all requires two people to operate the
palm fronds are probably decorative
maybe maybe load-bearing
but this two-person console isn't
everything this is just the user
interface here's what's going on behind
the scenes this instrument is massive
if the Hammad is inconvenient furniture
then the telharmonium was in the
convenient architecture its weight is
estimated at 200 tons so your hamon is
already three orders of magnitude ahead
you'll see the build materials here
includes bricks and mortar only three of
these were ever built but they were
designed for mass listening the output
was the telephone system so you could
call your operator any time of day and
ask to be connected to tell harmonium
then music would be piped into your home
you could take one of their provided
paper cones and wrap it around your
telephone receiver to amplify the sound
and there you have it a voice-activated
music streaming service in 1906 so for
the better part of a century now you're
Hammond spend a more convenient
alternative to that monstrosity but
still not convenient enough a hammond
b-3 with pedal board and bench is about
420 pounds Leslee 120
at a Leslie 122 is another hundred 40
pounds in fact once this talk was
accepted the conference Alex asked me if
I could make use of a ham and if he
could get one on stage of course I said
yes
I would probably embarrass myself
playing to this crowd of professionals
but I would certainly try
I've always wanted to perform green
onions on stage he was able to locate a
few Hammonds but was unable to find
anyone who would transport one for an
acceptable fee once again too heavy for
its own good so we have to make this
thing lighter this talk is about roto a
series of embedded Hammond organ
simulators that I've written for fun
my main goal in giving this talk is
removing this eight-year curse I
apologize if any of you end up with it
instead I was really getting into music
of handling Hammond music of various
sorts around the time I started down the
path that became my career as a software
developer now my withered programmer
arms are unable to lift the speaker much
less the Hamet itself this is a
super-heavy organ most of my musical
efforts went to the electric guitar
instead which is a favorite instrument
of weaklings around the world roto
started a few years ago and my work at
little turned briefly to embedded
software development hears this is a
remote control for a set-top box that
never made the market as a wireless link
to the computer and presents a USB
keyboard trackpad microphone and an
accelerometer that we exposed as a three
axis joystick I really enjoyed working
on this thing after years of writing
Linux desktop software and HTTP services
this was a totally different headspace
and it was really amazing to work on
something that had physical interaction
with the world at about the same time
the Arduino was becoming really hot as a
platform all of these things bounced
around my head along with a lot of
hammond music and one night as I watched
cosmos it felt like Carl Sagan was
speaking to me and me alone when he
famously said if you wish to make green
onions from scratch you must first
invent the universe
so I started to slowly piece together
that universe what I'll present today is
by no means the only way to model a
Hammond and Leslie and this is very
firmly a hobbyist project but I think
it'll give you some guidance on how to
start thinking about modeling some
fairly compact complex instruments I
bought an Arduino and a medieval shield
a headphone jack and a MIDI compliant
hardware interface by Colin Cunningham
this combination allows you to convert
MIDI messages which is a standard
protocol spoken by thousands of hardware
devices to audio output a River program
that took MIDI messages for the main
user controls of the Hammond its
keyboard and it's draw bars draw bars
are a set of sliding levers used to
shape the sound of a Hammond my program
read MIDI control messages now put an
organ like waveform the Arduino ended up
being underpowered for the task at least
that I as I understood it at a time I
attempted a design that was too true to
the original Hammond sound modeling each
of its 91 oscillators individually and
given the strict timing requirements of
audio programming I was unable to mix
those tone wheels fast enough to satisfy
the audio sample sample rate audio
programming is a real-time environment
human hearing is extremely sensitive to
fluctuations in frequency in order to
produce something that sounds good you
must output your waveform according to a
very accurate clock tick tick if you're
unable to keep up with the clock you end
up duplicating or dropping samples and
it sounds terrible my Arduino
implementation could only advance and
mix about a third of the Hammonds tone
wheels in the time it was given so that
was a showstopper
I briefly entertained the idea the idea
of tone wheel coprocessors which would
be additional microcontrollers that each
produce a portion of the output waveform
but I never really attempted that
project I put it down for a few days
which turned to weeks months and 10
years about five years later I woke up
one morning with a Eureka moment the
simulating the Hammonds 91 oscillators
looks kind of like this you decide the
volume of each based on the keys that
are pressed and the drawbars that are
better pulled out and then you advance
and mix the oscillators each key that
you press can activate up to nine new
tone wheels this is computationally
intensive particularly on a slow clocked
microcontroller and it's one of the room
reasons why additive synthesis has a
reputation for difficulty but yet so the
oscillator frequencies in the Hammond
are constrained by the gear ratios and
machining techniques of the time and
they're very close to exact harmonic
multiples of each other but essentially
running independently of each other if I
relax the requirement to model the
individual oscillators and instead
modeled their ideal harmonic
relationships then I can treat the
drawbar settings as parameters for a
more complex oscillator build a single
waveform and play that back once for
each keys at key that's pressed only one
oscillator per key
that's that allows a normal trade-off in
the synthesizer world called pathani we
can do less work if fewer keys are
pressed it's not unusual to see an
instrument that only supports four note
polyphony or ten notes or even one many
of the analog synthesizers that we know
and love like this mini Moog where
monophonic the Hammond however is a
fully polyphonic instrument if you press
down all 122 keys you will get 122
sounds it sounds terrible terrible it's
like a real cacophony I guess that's
cacophonic anyway I feel it's an
important constraint for stimulating the
instrument so the Arduino was out for
the synthesizer that I want to build but
with that performance realization I
decided to revive my project but by then
they were better alternatives the
Arduino this is Paul stop engines teensy
board where when the Arduino where the
Arduino is powered by an 8-bit
microcontroller the teensy is 32-bit the
cortex m4 it does more work per cycle
has a higher clock rate and has a much
more flexible USB interface so it can
implement many more types of devices and
Paul supports a really excellent audio
API out of the box and over 1 USB cable
the teen's he can take USB MIT USB MIDI
messages in and then output over them
out put them over a USB audio device in
fact I have the complete Hardware
develop environment for the synthesizer
here or you can buy his $20 audio board
which is shown underneath the teensy
here and then you get a headphone output
and an SD card for storing sound file
it's really nice to build a small
sampler so let's define the scope for
today's project first I want to
implement a Hammond b3 organ and Leslie
122 speaker cabinet which is the most
common model of speaker paired with
Hammonds where there were differences
over time
I kind of arbitrarily picked 19:56 as
the vintage for these devices
I want my instrument to be fully
polyphonic so we're gonna be
implementing 91 oscillators at the
original frequencies the leslie is a
beast on its own it's a vacuum tube
amplifier and a speak and speaker
cabinetry with rotating elements so as
the patent says a rotatable tremulous
sound producer we all know what that is
the base speaker is fixed to the cabinet
but has this scoop mounted to it that
rotates around throwing the bass around
in a circular pattern the treble speaker
feeds this horn which is mounted on a
turntable so the higher frequencies are
also cast around in a circular pattern
the bass scoop and the treble horn spin
at different rates and in different
directions from each other and the
control on a Hammond allows you to
select either a faster or slower set of
speeds so a lot of motion going on
already not to mention what happens when
you place it in a physical space and get
you know bouncing off of walls we're
gonna control the instrument of our MIDI
which is the musical instrument digital
interface this is a serial protocol
standardized in 1983 for instrument
control here's a hardware MIDI interface
I'm gonna retcon this phone port here as
another attempt at tell harmonium style
music streaming I welcome feedback but
don't you dare well actually my MIDI fax
phone port many messages look like this
will be reacting to note on and note off
events as keypresses as well as control
change events for knobs and draw bars
and such if you hear midi and you think
of awful sounding since you're
half-right as a control protocol midi is
agnostic to the sounds produced but a
lot of us were first introduced to midi
by low powered software since in the
early days of sound cards and yeah they
sounded pretty bad
they've been traditionally two ways to
get midi into a device either this 5 pin
Dean connector or more recently USB
since the team she already wants a USB
cable for programming in power I'm just
gonna stick to that for now as of last
month there's a third method they've
approved a standard wiring for MIDI over
three over a three and a half millimeter
jack
that means that the teensy audio board
could also itself the hardware midi
receiver if you implement rs-232 serial
most ports can be a serial port if you
try hard and believe in yourself
for hardware I'm gonna target the teensy
3.6 which is a $30 variant of the teensy
board that runs at a very speedy hundred
hundred and eighty megahertz
the teensy Audio API supports CD quality
audio so stereo output at forty four
point one kilohertz and sixteen bout
16-bit values the synthesizer will be
controlled over USB MIDI and output
either back to the computer or through
the audio boards headphone jack here's a
slide for those whose heads have been
rotating with all the imperial units the
Hammond is three orders of magnitude
lighter than the telharmonium but our
teensy is five orders of magnitude
lighter still my kitchen scale isn't
super accurate at this weight but my
right by my reckoning you can send two
teensy synthesizers with 150 cent stamp
in the United States no problem getting
getting one of those on stage for
strangely here's a to-do list as an
overview of what we'll be covering we'll
start with a single audible sine wave
oscillator which we can duplicate to
produce the Hammonds 91 oscillator block
will simulate the vibrato and percussion
effects on the organ and control its
volume with a swell pedal our two main
building blocks for the leslie will be a
tube amplifier distortion model and a
tremolo effects which will integrate
into the the hammond vibrato code we'll
use that to simulate the Wesley's two
rotating speakers and then virtually mic
the whole thing for stereo recording
right let's see what the hammond looks
like here's my block diagram that the
hammond b-3
it has this Bank of oscillators
equivalent to the big generator looking
things into Tel harmonium picture on the
Hammond sound generation is performed by
spinning tone wheels that are shaped to
induce a sine wave tone and a pickup the
dark shape pickup that's beside them
there are ninety one of these and a
hammond each producing tone at a fixed
frequency there are two keyboards on the
Hammond called manuals in the organ
tradition each has its own set of draw
bars you can be playing two different
voicings at the same time but they're
both controlling tone wheels from the
same oscillator block so everything ends
up getting mixed together there are two
sets of draw bars one for each manual
and they control how much of each of
nine harmonic frequencies are mixed in
for each key that's pressed down so each
key will trigger up to nine tune wheels
but two keys may activate the same tone
wheel here's a closer look at one set of
draw bars showing the range of tones
that could be activated by pushing down
that single C key that's highlighted in
the second octave
you'll get five different octaves of the
same note plus four other musically
useful intervals here's an audio clip
that plays the tones from each drawbar
in order
[Music]
[Music]
you can see we already have like that
there's there's something very handy
about that sound with just these these
nine oscillators playing together so
then there are a few audio effects the
oscillator output feeds into a vibrato
and chorus circuit which is the main
onboard effect for the Hammonds here's
what it sounds like to sweep through the
vibrato and the chorus settings on a b3
[Music]
a second effect called percussion
introduces a sharp transient sound
whenever you start playing from silence
I'm switching here to playing legato
where the percussion is not triggering
anymore so what happens when you start
from allowance it's the output the whole
thing goes through a volume or swell
circuit that's controlled by a rocking
foot pedal and that's just sounds like a
volume change
[Music]
here's this well pedal from a modern
Hammond along with a set of foot pedals
for bass notes these control tone wheels
1 through 12 which are shaped to produce
a more complex tone we're gonna ignore
them for the purposes of today's talk
but they feed is the same tone wheels
and the tools that you're about to get
will allow you to implement those two so
the first thing we need to do is to get
the teensy to make a hammock noise and
to do that we're gonna model its set of
oscillators the ham is called a tone
wheel organ what does that mean it
produces it sounds by spinning these
specially shaped disks next to the dark
shape pickups that are beside them
here's a top-down view we're now looking
at the edges of all the tone wheels
there 91 of these in the Hammonds
oscillator block each shaped and geared
to produce a sine wave tone to a single
fixed frequency we need to simulate the
oscillator block and to do that we need
to first build a single oscillator so
how do we trick a computer into making
noise we create an oscillating C signal
in the audible frequency range so we
have to calculate the output voltage at
each point in time forty forty four
point one kilohertz means that we have
about twenty-one microseconds to compute
each sample which is very constraining
if you're used to thinking in
milliseconds you will also need a very
accurate clock to guide when you output
that voltage in fact Lawrence Hammonds
prior experience was clock making before
the organ the Hammond company produced
synchronous clocks which are clocks that
are times by the frequency of the AC
power signal this is a reasonably
accurate way to keep time probably your
stove your microwave oven uses a
synchronous clock but occasionally that
system breaks down maybe some of you are
affected earlier this year when an
electrical power dispute between Kosovo
and Serbia Serbia is cascaded to slow
clocks across Europe by about six
minutes you'll see similar problems
running a sixty Hertz Hammond in a 50
Hertz country or worse running on
generator power at a music festival for
the first the organs gonna run flat on a
generator to the frequency may be all
over the place the teensy audio api
takes care of this clocking for us you
feed it buffers of 128 samples and they
will output each sample in time if
you're working with a different system
then you may need to configure Hardware
timers to give you an interrupt whenever
you need to output the samples all right
we have an accurate clock
how about calculating the samples
themselves
we're gonna use a technique that's
called direct digital synthesis this is
a really powerful technique for
producing any audio waveform and hinges
on one really simple realization you can
treat an unsigned integer as an
oscillator if you repeatedly add a
constant to it eventually the oscillator
is going to overflow it's gonna wrap
back around to zero and you get this
sawtooth pattern as a result we're gonna
take that sawtooth and use it as an
index into a lookup table for a sine
wave so we sweep through the sign up but
repeatedly the teens he has 16-bit
assigned audio output so we'll make
these in 16s and we're gonna make it 256
elements long we'll maintain a 32-bit
counter that we update as sample stick
by that becomes our sawtooth will use
its top eight bits as our index into the
sign tables so we don't have to perform
bounds checking when we're whenever
we're indexing into that table the
overflow behavior on this counter means
that we can keep adding to it and it'll
eventually wrap back around to zero so
let's add a constant increment at each
sample the increment decides how fast
the counter overflows and therefore how
fast we sweep through that signed table
if we set the increment to 2 to the 24th
then at each tick we're gonna output the
next sample from the lookup table just
one one after another well loop every
256 tagged ticks taking along at forty
four point one kilohertz we now have a
sign oscillator at 172 Hertz which is
just above an F and we'll see how to
adjust that frequency in a moment here's
a struct definition sounded kind of
pseudocode for the oscillator and a
function that returns the next sample
value we increment the counter we shift
it to get the index and then we look up
the sign value at that index
we'll call the index into our table the
phase accumulator because it accumulates
changes to the phase or the shift of the
sine wave which makes the increment our
phase increment we can play anything
that we want as long as it's one note
truly one note song is very boring
indeed so we're gonna want to change the
frequency of our oscillator if we
decrease the phase increment from there
then those top bits in the counter are
gonna overflow less frequently and we'll
get a lower frequency sine wave if we
increase the phase increment then
they'll overflow faster and we'll get a
higher frequency sine wave
calculating that phase increment for a
fixed frequency is maybe not obvious but
it is really easy we divide our divide
up our three two bits worth of counter
by forty four point one kilohertz and
then multiply that by the frequency that
we want we can build a table of phase
accumulators for the 91 frequencies in
the tone wheel generator and maintain a
set of 91 phase accumulators that track
the rotational state of all the trip the
tone wheels a nice side effect of this
approach is that the remaining bits in
the phase accumulator are an indication
of how far you are between entries and
lookup table so you can use those to
interpolate between the indexed value in
the next for higher precision and much
better audio fidelity so let's set the
volume of this oscillator we'll add a
16-bit volume field to each of the tone
wheels because we know that we're gonna
need to mix them together based on
different volumes and then each sine
wave oscillator looks like this if you
replace the sine table this can be used
to playback any waveform at any
frequency and volume with excellent
audio fidelity this is a really great
building block on the previous slide I
shifted the result right by 16 bits when
calculating the output sample one of the
things that I've gotten out of doing
audio work is the ability to think in
the number of bits that each value
contributes to to some result
multiplying n bits by n bits gives you
an N plus and n plus n bit value that
you can then shift that either way in
order to produce something in a
different output range having an N bit
and an N bit value together requires one
more bit then whichever is is larger and
then again you can shift that to
wherever you want this is hugely useful
when you're starting to reason about
whether adding together two things is
going to overflow the 16 bit range of
the the output so tying it all together
all we need to do to produce the whole
sign oscillator block is to run 91 of
these in parallel so let's see what they
all sound like together
so apologies to anyone who was dozing
off this yeah this sounds awful so we're
gonna need to play only some of the tone
wheels at once wiring up the manuals and
the drawbars as a matter of handling the
MIDI callbacks as left as an exercise
for you we're gonna move on back to the
physical Hammond the next focus is the
vibrato and chorus circuit vibrato is an
effect that causes a signal to waver in
frequency caused a chorus in effect that
makes the sound fuller the Hammond has
six different vibrato and chorus
settings will sweep through them all
again hear and hear that hear how they
sound
[Music]
so physically this is implemented as a
variable-length delay line afraid that's
not gonna that's not gonna be easy to
read you can think of this delay line
like a slow wire with a fixed writer on
one end and a reader that moves back and
forth along it you could do the same
thing with an exposed cassette tape and
a moving read head and maybe some of you
recognize this setup from a physics
class it's a classic example of a fixed
audio source and a moving listener so it
induces a Doppler shift in frequency
when the read head is moving toward the
writer the wave form becomes squashed
this shifts the audio frequency slightly
higher same as a listener moving toward
a fixed sound source when the read head
is moving away from the writer the
waveform is stretched in the audio
frequency is shifted lower when this
movement repeats back and forth you get
that wavering of the input signal on a
Hammond this is created with rotational
motion in the scanner block if we can
see a well rotational arrow there the
Hammond has three vibrato settings which
adjust how far along the delay line the
reader moves and therefore the depth of
the vibrato effect then the same three
depths are also available as chorus
settings which mix the dry signal back
into the vibrato the result is two
voices one wavering and one fixed which
gives you a much fuller sound we're
gonna use a similar model to the
physical one a delay line with a fixed
writer and a moving reader the reader is
gonna scan back and forth along the
delay line overtime delay line is really
easy in software we'll use a ring buffer
the scanner in the Hammond produces a
roughly triangular scan pattern so this
is what the read offset from the right
head looks like over time the read
offset is just another oscillator just
like the sine wave so all we need is a
triangle woke up table a phase
accumulator and an offset a depth
parameter used exactly like volume
before adjust the limits of the read
heads oscillations and therefore the
strength of a brought of effect our next
effect is called percussions on the ham
and this gives you a little chirp at the
beginning of each tone it disables one
of the draw bars while notes are being
held and instead it applies it sound
briefly as the keys or first press down
if any note is being held percussion
doesn't sound and you have to release
all the keys to get it back a bouncy
playing style allows you to sound
percussive notes or tie existing notes
together as desired percussion plays
briefly it's about half a second but
every key that you press down during
that time can contribute a harmonic to
the percussion sound so several tone
wheels may take part at this point we
could implement this by adding a time
component to the oscillator block
indicating the volumes of the tone
wheels over that time period
but that really complicates the tone
wheel control logic which so far is only
driven by those keydown and keyup events
so I chose to implement percussion by
adding a second whole set of tone wheels
with a volume envelope positioned after
it these are updating the same key down
and up paths and so they produce a
continuous tone while keys are down but
they feed into this volume envelope that
plays the percussion oscillator at full
volume and the key first goes down but
it rapidly decays back to silent here's
the block diagram volume envelope is a
typical synthesizer block and is
provided by the TC Audio API so I've
just used that here again it's what the
percussion sounds like I'm gonna switch
back and forth between a legato style
that doesn't trigger percussion and one
that releases all keys so that it does
play it's kind of subtle but it's a
really important part of the voicing of
a lot of music
progression has a few controls that
switch which harmonic is played the
length of the decay and it's volume and
these are all really straightforward to
implement with this design last and
maybe least the hammond pedal bard has a
volume pedal called swell in the organ
tradition i've connected the MIDI signal
for this to the output volume of the
organ so component wise we've built a
bulk sine oscillator and an emulation of
the Hammond vibrato circuit we've added
the Hammonds percussion effect and it's
well pedal tying these together with
teensy audio and MIDI of libraries gives
a full simulation of the b3 for the
purposes of time I've glossed over a few
things but key click loudness robbing
and harmonic leakage if you're aware of
any of those things are all physical
effects that are really easy to
implement with this single volume per
tone wheel
design this is the b3 just as Lorenz
Hammett intended but it's not quite what
players wanted brief digression on the
way to Leslie the Hammond b3 was
introduced in 1954 but strip away the
percussion to make some tweaks to the
tone wheel generator and it's pretty
similar to the original ham and a from
1935
that's the organ that was a quick
success in churches and theaters where
it replaced pipe and reed organs a giant
sound for giant spaces there's where it
got its gospel start Reverend Clarence
Cobbs of the First Church of deliverance
in Chicago one of the first
african-american pastors with his own
radio show replaced his church piano
with a Hammond that's the seed that
spread the Hammond to jazz soul rock and
most every genre of music but first it
needs a little something extra though
Donald Leslie was an engineer who felt
the Hammond lacked something in smaller
spaces the Hammonds accurate oscillators
sounded dull shrill and still to his ear
he designed a speaker cabinet with
rotating elements to give the motion to
the sound of the organ and presented it
to Lawrence Hammond who hated it Hammond
sent and packing he had noted interest
in changing the clockwork perfection of
his organ tone as an aside is hard to
say whether Hammond intended for his
organ to sound like anything in
particular many accounts are that he was
tone-deaf and completely uninterested in
improving the sound of his instrument
this is one of the reasons why the
Hammond from 1935 does not sound any
different from from you know the last
tone wheel Hammond produce Leslie left
Hammonds office and brought a speaker to
market over the next few decades
Hammond fart hard against it he
redesigned the speaker connection and
attempt to obsolete existing Leslie's he
forbade his distributors from selling it
techniques which were still familiar
with today let's hear what Leslie
thought of selling into this hostile
environment I was amazed at all the
publicity Hammond created for me by
their continuous bad-mouthing of my
products this word-of-mouth advertising
was so good that from the start until
the company was sold to CBS in 1965 no
advertising was ever needed and my
problem has always been keeping up
production to match sales this is 24
years without advertising followed by a
successful exit for Leslie's tech
startup
it took it took a few years after
Hammonds death before his company
recognized the Leslie speaker for its
contributions the organs popularity and
eventually it bought Leslie production
by the way I like to think that Don
Leslie is the strange loop attendee in
this story he's building on a very solid
engineering foundation but taking things
in the creative direction that nobody
really expected so let's look at the
Leslie here's a rough diagram we need to
simulate the effect of the two rotating
elements plus the growl of the tube
amplifier when the speaker is over
driven here's a clip of the Leslie
switching from slow to fast the change
is abrupt here I've been implemented the
the momentum of the moving elements so
it just goes directly there
so let's first take a closer look at the
Leslie Space River the bass speaker has
a baffle mounted around it sort of a
drum with a scoop to guide the sound the
baffle spins around the speaker and
casts the sound around in a circle the
main effect of this baffle is a
modulation of volume since the sound is
louder when it's directed toward you and
it's quieter when it's directed away
it's spinning in a circle so it's
roughly a sinusoidal rise and fall of
volume modular modulation of volume like
this is commonly called a tremolo effect
and we're going to need to build one of
those next is the treble horn this horn
is effectively mounted on a turntable so
the speaker itself spins in a circle you
see two horns here but only one produces
sound the other one is therefore
mechanical balanced this has the same
tremolo effect as the bass speaker since
the horns pointed toward and then away
from you but because the horn has length
the sound source also moves toward and
away from you at the same rate this is a
radius of about 8 inches you've got 16
inches of delay at you know whatever the
current speed of sound is between its
closest and as farthest points in the
vibrato effects we had a fixed sound
source with a moving listener here we
have a moving sound source with a fixed
listener relatively speaking these have
the same effect so if we adapt the
vibrato simulation from the Hammond to
modulate volume also we can use the same
bit of code for the vibrato and a
Hammond the rotating bass baffle and the
rotating treble horn I have ended up
calling this effect am/fm because it
performs both amplitude and frequency
modulation so here's the block diagram
for our Leslie simulation with the two
AM FM effects highlighted we'll need to
split the signal from the Hammond into
the bass and the treble signals and for
this we can use a filter from the teensy
library I've set the filter frequency
here to 800 Hertz which come straight
from the Leslie documentation and sent
the low and the high pass outputs to the
two speakers the Leslie also distorts
when over driven with a characteristic
growl so in front of this we're going to
need an amplifier simulation and here's
what the growl sounds like
[Music]
the effect of this sort of distortion is
a flattening of the audio Peaks when the
signal is low we want to treat the seek
signal normally but when it's high we
want to squash the peaks this is called
a soft clipping effect we have plenty of
RAM and the total range of output values
is only 16 bits so we'll use another
lookup table here we easily shrink the
table if we need to by interpolating
between values if necessary because the
incoming samples are signed will use
them to index relative to the middle of
the lookup table you can see that zeros
marks there in the center this has a
roughly linear response in the middle of
the table at low volumes but as you
adjust the swell pedal of the of the
organ louder than you drive the Leslie
harder and you push your samples more
into the flattened curves on the sides
that produces more saturated overdrive
so so far the entire signal chain has
been mono but if you remember the teensy
has stereo output at this point we have
two choices we can place this speaker
simulated in a room and simulate the
reverberations as it spins around or we
can simulate the speaker being mics for
recording the room simulation will
replicate more of a live feel the
microphones something that you might
hear on an album I did the latter
because it was a lot easier so here's a
common microphone placement for
recording a Leslie you've got left and
right microphones each 90 degrees apart
from each other and pointing toward the
speaker we could add stereo outputs the
am/fm effect and track the the rotation
the position that's relative to each of
these two microphones but that
complicates one of our fundamental
building blocks there's not really any
difference between the output of a
single speaker with two microphones and
two speakers one shifted 90 degrees each
with their own microphone so we'll
create a whole new set of speakers start
them off with a phase that leads the
first by a quarter circle and call that
the other channel this leaves us with a
nice stereo effect that sweeps between
the ref the right in the left channels
as the speakers rotate so for our model
model the Leslie we built a distortion
filter and expanded the Hammonds vibrato
simulation the handle volume modulation
as well as frequency we combined two
instances of that new effect to simulate
the Leslie's two rotating speakers and
then duplicated that whole thing again
to give us
stereo output so let's wrap the whole
thing up
I hope you've gotten a sense of how to
model the physical processes in the
Hammond organ the Leslie speaker with a
decent direction to head in for making
your own noises my code is up on github
in this rotary PO if you're looking for
a turnkey sand prepare to be a little
bit just disappointed it has the right
shape of things and it's a good place to
see how to wire up the teensy API into
custom audio devices but there are some
known audio glitches at this point and
control is not fully wired up so I
expect my journey to continue there and
finally I have the ham and Leslie
stickers we passed some of the round
some of them around earlier if you
didn't get one then I've got a few got
way too many make sure that you place
the Leslie speaker to the right of the
Hammonds because the motor the AC motor
on the left side of the organ tends to
induce unwanted noise in the speaker
that should be obvious from the
perspective on the two stickers now I've
always dreamed of playing a Hammond on
stage to bring things full circle here a
few bars of green onions play it through
roto and thank you very much for your
attention
[Applause]
[Music]
we song but I can play
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]